réunion hebdomadaire pour l'équipe de
vie de vue bien vu à quelques semaines
du lancement de cette nouvelle marque de
lunettes versaillaise l'heure est aux
derniers ajustements pour cette jeune
start up imaginé il ya un peu plus de
deux ans cette gamme de lunettes
prémontées propose notamment des verts
multivision pour fait en haut du verre
vous allez avoir un verre qui va être
ici sans correction est en bas du verre
vous allez avoir un verre comme sur des
prêts montée avec une correction de plus
une plus ce qui permet d'utiliser ce n'
est tout le temps pour voir aussi bien
de loin que de près l'équipe composée en
partie d'opticiens a misé sur des
matériaux naturels
les lunettes sont composées
majoritairement de coton un matériau
durable dans le temps c'est ce qui a
notamment séduit les designers c'était
quelque chose qui nous intéressait aussi
énormément dans ce projet c'est d'être
sur quelque chose de qualitatif est
aussi un matériau qui est beaucoup plus
intéressant que de faire un énième une
énième pré montées en plastique injecté
c'est important pour nous d'être sur ce
matériau qui est un très beau matériaux
et qu'on n'utilise pas assez on a
constaté que le secteur de l'optique
aujourd'hui est un secteur en pleine
mutation
on a des nouvelles normes législatives
avec la loi amont des remboursements au
niveau des mutuelles qui diminue on sait
que le pouvoir d'achat au niveau des
français aujourd'hui est faible et les
coûts optiques sont assez élevés donc
l'idée c'est vraiment de proposer ce
produit qualitatif un prix à moins de 40
euros pour justement répondre à un vrai
besoin au niveau de la population
en plus des verts multivision vie du
bien vu propose également des verts qui
protègent de la lumière bleue renvoyé
par certains appareils numériques 18
modèles seront disponibles au printemps
prochain sur un site internet dédié mais
aussi chez des opticiens et des
pharmacies partenaires dans les yvelines
et à paris